[Music]
most alive yeah the time I felt most
alive hmm questions us alive I was in
Croatia with my new Australian boyfriend
that I had just met and I was falling in
love and I felt alive because when
you're in love to feel alive
I would say the time I felt most alive
was when I got that time only enough I
have stayed abroad last semester right
when I got off the plane it was amazing
that I actually be a different place it
was the first time I ever left the
country that's probably the most I'll
have ever felt
um I feel like any time I'm like out
nature naked I feel pretty alive what
happen often
when the situations arise oh no it so be
honest with you like who's going through
stuff he started to feel like like wow
you know
a lot of times yeah that's like
peripheral yeah probably when I first um
come I got it probably when I went on
the lightning freezer at Hershey Park
for the first time I may have lost it
pair of parasailing with my daughter
over there a month ago my friend
accidentally stabbed me in her leg that
was that was pretty likely that he was
fooling around with a with a hatchet and
he threw it up and it came down
the time I feel most alive
probably when I was on a boat we were
going like really fast my wedding day
the moment my wife her bride-to-be at
that moment walked down the aisle and I
saw her for the first time and all of
our favorite people were surrounding us
and at that
couldn't get any better than that
time I felt most alive was probably the
other night with my parents at this
restaurant called la Sevilla and we were
dancing and we were doing the salsa oh
man done
I don't think I've done anything
exciting at all this is horrible oh my
gosh I'm so sorry I got married last
November so that's probably the most
surreal I've ever felt but you know
you're sitting there everybody's there
for you and they're celebrating you so
that's probably the most exciting thing
that's happened like just outside
experiencing advance
that's when I feel most alive but out in
my room listening to heathens about 21
pilots probably what I had my boys
it gave me a better purpose in life that
I have little beings to take care of and
somebody besides just myself
[Music]
ah I guess when I solve a problem that
I've been working on for a long time
anytime then I just get amped up it can
be the smallest thing I get amped but
I'm on the stage doing my music
time I feel most alive when I joined the
Navy oh shoot um actually probably
yesterday I went to Disneyland and we're
just on Splash Mountain my friend was
like losing it cuz she hates getting wet
and I was just like laughing the entire
time time I felt that's deep the time I
felt most alive okay I'm gonna go home
and I'm gonna have all these things
running through my head
well no overland until right now when is
the time I felt most alive my fondest
birthday my favorite memory right now is
my 50th birthday hiking down Havasupai
Falls in Phoenix Arizona or northern
Arizona with like my best friend's of 40
years and there was like ten of us and
it was exhilarating and again no social
media and now camping and yeah the town
I feel most alive was yesterday phone
not here two days ago well we went to
probably after had my kids after had the
girls like it's pretty it's a big huge
miracle and it's pretty impressive what
we can do with our body is so
that's a tough one well I probably
probably say a couple days ago when I
proposed to my fiancee
so probably the time ago when I got
engaged alive yeah
probably the first time I smoke weed
right now
right now what do you do now
volleyball probably this week serving
for the first time in Costa Rica
traveling to all national parks in Utah
I felt probably most alive
when I want
well I can describe you the moment that
I snapped into existence I remember the
first thing I remember is seeing a
picture of me and my brothers and then
immediately I remember crawling and that
was it so I guess I would be the moment
I felt most alive was like the first
moment I remember yeah I remember just
crawling I I remember not being able to
talk to all okay if you could choose the
question I would ask people tomorrow
it'll be
[Music]
what song describes you
[Music]
you